Northern California also under serious
threat the campfire in Northern
California has forced more than 50,000
people out of their homes in the town of
Paradise it has been nearly wiped out
that fire happened on Friday
firefighters are scrambling right now to
save any homes or structures that are
still standing this morning we are
learning about the people who risk their
lives to save others they're workers at
the Feather River Hospital loaded
patients into their personal vehicles
and drove them to safety while thousands
of buildings burned around them just
extraordinary scenes
Maria Villarreal is in Paradise where
she spoke to one of those staff members
Maria good morning to you
well good morning burned-out cars like
this and scorched trees lined one of the
roads that leads up to that Feather
River Hospital you know it's a man just
like this they are sobering reminders
for those that were able to survive the
campfire and get out we spoke with one
nurse who said that he actually wasn't
sure if he was going to make it out he
recounted his harrowing near-death
escape with several patients in the back
seat of his car the window is so hot I
can't even touch the window right now
this was the view out darryl wilkins car
window as he and his patients fled the
raging flames in Paradise how close did
the fire get it was everywhere Wilkin a
registered nurse was one of several
Feather River hospital staff members who
helped evacuate patients as the camp
fire closed in zero fear at any point
that they could even die in your car as
you're trying to get away sure Wilkin
had three patients too critical in his
car vehicles around him were on fire he
thought they may be next so he and his
patients called their families to say
goodbye what do you do when you go
through hell won't you just keep going
it took them more than three hours to
get through hell you're still shaking
I'm still shaking every time I talk
about it
hearses were on standby Sunday as 10
search and recovery teams combed through
the rubble in Paradise this cannot be
easy it's know it's difficult it's
horrible
Cory Honi is the Butte County Sheriff
coroner he says a mobile DNA lab has
been sent to help identify victims
there's the possibility that there could
be fatalities that are remains that were
completely consumed by the fire I didn't
want to lose anybody
Daryl Wilkin is still rattled by his
narrow escape but says he and his
coworkers just did what was right we
have not just an obligation to our
patients but we have an obligation in
humanity and we have to do our jobs
regardless of the adverse conditions
more than 200 people right now are
reported missing in this area so far all
of the patients for that hospital they
are accounted for but four employees are
still considered missing as of right now
they continue to search the areas for
anybody that might be missing any sort
of remains in this area Jeff as far as
we know right now Wilkins tells us the
wing of the hospital that he was in
actually burned completely down to the
ground just moments after he was able to
escape Jeff all right Maria thank you